so here's a video a lot of you
specifically asked me to make first of
all here's the background a few weeks
ago I made this video with my neighbors
Danny and Emily all about numbers in a
tin of spaghetti at the end of the video
I offered them four pounds each this is
what four pounds looks like or I offered
to put this piece of paper on eBay and
give the proceeds to them her happen
eBay eBay okay yeah and the winning bid
which came from this chap in Australia
was well somewhat more than four pounds
each now those of you who followed the
auction desperately wanted to see the
reaction when the kids got the money so
this is what five hundred and fifty
pounds looks like in one-pound coins
eBay obviously have a taken their share
of things and here's that reaction you
wanted to say
they will know that one pound boys I
don't know how much how much do you
think is there so that's all yours so
what would you do if you were ten and
thirteen years old and got given all
that money have a think about it
thanks thank you I've actually got a
note here from Danny and Emily who have
thought about it this is what they spent
it on a couple of treats for themselves
a present for their sister who wasn't
able to be involved in the filming
taking the whole family including their
mum and dad out for a family meal and
sponsoring a toilet in a third world
country through this scheme so they're
giving a fair portion of what they made
to charity and that's not where the
story ends actually the people from
hinds who make the number Ettie they
were fascinated by the video they
actually sent a couple of gift packs to
the kids but they also sent all these
tins of baked beans Danny and Emily's
father actually works for a local
charity here in Nottingham helping
people in times of need with furniture
and food and things like that and these
baked beans are going to go to those
people I think making YouTube videos is
really fun and we do all sorts of crazy
things that you get to watch like going
into gold bullion vaults and rolling
yahtzee's and blowing things up I don't
think it's that often we think about the
serious things in life and people who
may be less fortunate than us this is
probably a good time of year to think
about it and this is probably also a
good video in which to think about it so
under this video I'm going to put some
links to charities and things like that
that maybe you want to make a
contribution to this year in particular
my life through the people I work with
and also family and friends has been
affected quite a lot by cancer and I
guess Cancer Research is something that
I think is really important so I've
actually set up a number file page a
JustGiving page where you can give money
towards cancer research and if that's
something that affects you or you can't
think of anything but want to contribute
that link is below
include the toilet charity that Danny
and Emily gave to he send in some
suggestions maybe I'll try and include
some others as well but it's just
something to think about and thanks for
all your support for numberphile and
thanks for everyone who bid on that
piece of paper for the kids that was a
lot of fun and we'll have more
numberphile videos so